this is a production of cornell
university
anyway uh i think everybody's aware of
the importance of the lakes
to the landscapes
i think that most residents are
clear that what happens in the
watersheds
is reflected in what goes on in the lake
and
what i want to do today is summarize
about
40 years of my experience with it
we've got some problems with units
and i guess i better try to get some of
this straightened out first
the volume of the lake is about
10 000 million cubic meters if that
means anything to you it's kind of up
there with national debt and stuff like
that
if a tornado sucked all the water out of
the lake it would take 10 to 15 years
for the lake to refill
the deepest parts about 400 feet so that
gives you an idea of what we're talking
about
now we're going to talk about we're
looking about concentrations of
phosphate which
instead of one with lots of zeros now
it's a lot of zeros and a small number
uh most of the
times we talk about parts per billion of
phosphate
that's
five times ten to the minus six grams
per liter or it's about five times ten
to the minus three
grams per cubic meter meter
but please note that most of the nitrate
is talked about in terms of parts per
million
which a thousand times more concentrated
than phosphate
one example that we'll see later
probably
if you put a cubic meter if you had a
pallet here with a cubic meter by the
way is about a
cubic yard
if you put that in the lake and
dissolved it you'd increase the
phosphate concentration
by about three to five parts per billion
that's just really chlorophyll
concentration is commonly parts per
billion micrograms per liter
and if you look at what goes on in this
early spring
chlorophyll concentration increases
as it parts per billion not equal parts
per billion of phosphate
carbon content of the algae is sort of
50 to 100 times the chlorophyll content
okay one of the things that's important
to think about is the biological
activity in
yugo lake depends on the photosynthesis
by the algae and that is that energy
from a photosynthesis
is an important
source of energy for all of the
biological activity in the lake
uh most of the things we're talking
about
the chlorophyll and the phosphate are
measured using standard universally
accepted methods
all of the data is online or in two
if
very
important
it cornell
so i've known it well some of this date
is mine but an awful lot of it isn't
what i really want to do is look this is
the theme
inputs of streams determines phosphate
in the lake deep lake
which determines phosphate in the
surface water in the summer or spring
and that determines the algal
proliferation in the summer and we
measure it by chlorophyll
so we're going to you're going to see
that a couple of times
five years ago i decided to assemble the
stream and light data from
1972 through 2011.
since
1972 i'd collected about 2000 water
samples
about 2 000 lake samples were available
i had a lot of professional interest
after i retired and i wanted to
challenge my brain and believe me this
has been a good challenge for my brain
in 1962 for a little history
environmental quality became a major
concern at the university
agriculture kind of realized food
production
agriculture and the environment were all
tied together
and the late bob young assembled a team
of professors sports docs grad students
research staff etc etc and i happened to
be
one of those
uh people
and during that period 1972
it was a very very active group
we produced several theses scientific
publications a book a bulletin
major emphasis on the lake stream water
agricultural economics
animal science manure management guess
what
rural sociology but the whole theme was
to integrate it
we
produced a book
and
these are the project authors
now integration of everything was a
major
purpose
the group met
for at least two hours every second week
for six years and we had a lot of
discussions and all everybody had to go
if they got money and bob young watched
he no he didn't
take a sentence but
he was really uh
a really i'm just an incredible leader
uh there are two people here i want to
talk about one is ray o'sui and of
course myself
but ray was the lake person
and we had
to start early on okay so how am i going
to analyze water samples and how is he
going to hand analyze lake samples so
that once the water gets in the lake
there's not some big you know clear for
something like that so we spent a lot of
time on that we exchanged
uh labs
samples between labs and so on so i want
to really point that out because later
it's going to become important
the other person i want to point out is
keith porter helped
edit the book and all of that
ed goyet is sitting back there had to
stand up can you
he was the guy that went out on weekends
and nights and whatever and took water
samples during the storm
so anyway he's said i'm glad to see him
here
okay
if we start with kind of the conclusions
from the 1977
thing the levels of algae in the lake
are determined by the dissolved
phosphorus
present in the lake in the early spring
and the other important issue
once you get enriched algae you can get
rid of it by just getting rid of the
phosphorus inputs real question is that
consistent with 1999 to 211 and all i
want to do is just throw this up there
don't pay much attention to it you see a
lot of it later i just want to see okay
here's the phosphate in the spring
chlorophyll in the summer and yeah
there's a lot of noise but it's surely
clear a clear relationship with two the
question is how did we get the phosphate
in the spring so let's start with cube
lake and it's watersheds and
this map defines the source of the
drainage
and the lake surface area is about
10 of the watershed area
now we adopted as our model watershed
fall creek
for several reasons first of all it has
a mix
of agricultural and forest land uses
which is fairly typical of the rest of
the watersheds so what we're going to do
is look at what happens with
fall creek and we're going to
extrapolate that to the rest of the
watersheds via this idea
the other important issue is we had usgs
flow data from 1926 to the present this
will turn out to be extremely important
second thing i sampled about a hundred
feet above the
usgs station
i walked over the sampling site on my
way to my office in the morning if i
took a sample i just put it in my
laboratory or did it did the processing
myself
and that's all close to my office
and
uh watersheds about 20 percent of the
watershed area this is a just a brief
map of the watershed itself
notice that there are two brant two main
branches uh freeville
it could trees on north from freeville
and then to the east
it's
virgil creek
we did other small villages
and population densities
basically
i think it's reasonable to say that it's
a pretty good
uh representation of most of the
watershed here's the
bridge at forest our
forest home and foot of
uh
next forest
i'm sorry
pleasant grove
see
okay but anyway what's important is you
see the
pathway along the edge of the bridge
that's where i took all the samples i
stored my sampling tools in the
superstructure of the bridge
uh and here's where i
here's where i sampled from and notice
it comes through there and it's pretty
well mixed
uh here's a nice winter scene low very
low flow
ice and snow are accumulated in the
watershed we get a
thaw and oh all sorts of funny things
happen notice how dark the water is
there's a lot of sediment in it there's
a lot of phosphorus in it and it's very
very important to take these samples
from steams like that here's another one
this is a summer storm
uh
this is a picture of the usgs
controls the stream
on a nice summer day
i use some landscapes notice the
agricultural land woods in the
background
more agricultural land notice that
background buildings and diversity of
crops and more forests
here's a just a view across the valley
and again
landscapes and
woods
here's a creek above freevale and notice
there's abundant vegetation along the
stream
notice the little
stones flat stones that are
there
these streams are pretty well
stabilized uh notice now that
there's a stream in the background in
the middle of this slide but look at the
uh
buffering between the stream and the
agricultural and this lake como at the
top of the creek here's the fall creek
before lake como again
notice the buffering
this is a virgil creek
and one of the things i want to
emphasize here don't worry about the
nitrate thing it's also a source of
phosphorus okay so let's get to the data
what i have here is
a summary from
72 to 2008
the log concentration the log of load
which is flow times
concentration so it's the amount of
substance or for this case phosphorus
taken to the lake versus the flow and
flow is always a convenient way to
to summarize the data
what i want you to notice though really
is to look at the difference in the
color
of the
sample points
the black ones are 72 to 75.
the red is 2006. the green is 2 000
2008.99
what i want to conclude from this is
the loading
has not changed depreciably in the
period 1972-2009
now
statistically i presume you might think
of a model that would enable you to do a
good statistical test
my attitude is hey you know i'm not
going to go there
i look at these so make up your mind uh
if you say ah forget about it i don't
believe it but hey we'll see this later
uh so how do you do well the one thing i
do want to point out here
notice the variability
in loads versus
one given flow
and you think oh my goodness it's a
sloppy laboratory work that is not
sloppy laboratory work we've done a lot
of samples in which you take consecutive
samples
within a few minutes of each other and
take them to the laboratory and there's
very little variation
if you wait a few hours and take another
sample you get into that variability
that you see there so how do we deal
with that variability the first way is
look at
load versus flow
and usually you can do some mathematics
of that and you can either use a log or
a linear scale
the big deal is take lots of samples
samples all seasons and years
sample storms low flow and everything
else because it takes that many samples
to really
get what you need to know
now i did here's another way to look at
the
data
this is a
concentration now it's not the quantity
it's the
concentration per unit volume
and instead of doing with flow i've done
it with
flow ranges
and
these different boxes are
0 to 50 cps
50 to 99 etc all the way up to
1500 to 2 000 cubic feet per second and
the last one is over 3 000
i don't know
you've probably
looked at
box plots before i pulled one
one little thing out and pulled it over
to the
left and that bottom of that box
is at the concentration that includes
everything below that concentration
or that's the 25 of the samples are
below that concentration
if you go to the median 50 percent of
course
the top of the box is 75 percent and the
whiskers 90 so
this is a convenient way to summarize
and what i finally did was just do a
regression of average on
uh average of the different
of so this is our equation that
converts flow
in cubic feet per second
to
concentration of
soluble phosphorus
terms of per
unit volume
you'll see this later
well okay now we've defined the load
and the concentration for fall creek
1972-2008
next we extrapolate to all the
watersheds
first approximation one thing that's
pretty well documented flow per unit of
drainage area is the same for all
watersheds
uh area fall creeks twenty in
the total
area of the
lake
lake shed
so
five times fall creek is equal to
uh
in input into what of all the watersheds
well you might expect the next
approximation okay
we're going to also
extrapolate the load
from fall creek to the whole watershed
well we've both
developed now the loading from
watersheds now we turn our attention to
how to relate this to phosphate in the
lake
and algal production
now there's two things about the lake
that are pretty important to understand
the first one is and i don't think
there's any controversy about this
fall and winter the lake cools
reaches four degrees
it's mixed early
by march the dissolved constituents in
the lake are equal north to south east
to west top to bottom etc etc
now during the summer things are a
little different because the
surface water warms up
and water floats on top and that's where
the solar radiation is
and the algal begin to grow and they
proliferate
primarily in the surface layer
so now we conclude that the phosphate in
the deep cold water
in the lake is an integrated average
of stream inputs over months and years
and recalls lake deeper than 60 meters
does not mix during the summer with the
warm surface
but it does in the winter time
so now the deep water
changes slowly over years
and it turns out we have a really really
good
uh
set of data on the deep water in the
lake
first of all the research in the 68 to
74
by ray oglesby and john barlow
sampled
the lake
all the depths
all a year
since then the lake source cooling
people have taken samples of the intake
for the lake source cooling which is
deep water 60 plus meters
so those two things we know what the
concentration
in the lake water has
been for something uh wait a minute
there's a missing slide here where is it
oh here it is
the graph on the left is
the concentration in the deep water
and
the x-axis is here
notice in the upper left-hand side
there's
the
68-74 data
and then beginning 25 years later
in 1999
the concentration has dropped to
uh somewhere around four or three to
four to five and then it gradually
increases as we
go from there so why this large
difference between 74 and 99
it's about eight if you compare
uh
99 and
uh 210
and it's if you go later it's about six
parts per million so why
well
we go back to we go back to our
1972 to 77 data
and if you you don't recall probably uh
the
phosphate and detergent was banned
beginning in 1973.
so we had
spent we spent a lot of time in
all our deliberations from
uh
72 to 77 on the impact of this
on
uh
the phosphate in the lake
and it turns out
that detergent p
this the phosphate in the detergent was
a very large fraction
of the total phosphate
going into the lake
from seward population as a matter of
fact the two together were about a half
a kilogram per cap per year
now by 2005
100 of the detergent p has disappeared
on top of that
the lake corner or the
ithaca sewage treatment plant
has removed
on the order probably a little more than
half of the excreted p
so this is a if you look at just the
sword population which of course that
the output from the sewer plant was
going directly into the lake it was
about 44 000 kilos per year for the
whole lake
for the 40 000 unsword about 11 000
kilos p per year
and the total is about 55. now
obviously these are kind of broad
generalizations
but if you look at that 10 thousand
million cubic meters of lake water
that's equivalent to about five to six
parts per billion
decrease
in what you would expect to find in the
lake
and
i think it's it's well knocking i can
document all of this
uh
if you want to find out about it you can
read the book
uh anyway now we're back to
looking at
this
uh difference between 99 and 2011
which is documented by the lake source
cooling data
and notice it does go from somewhere
around 5 to somewhere around 10 in that
period of time and so the question is
what happened
well again we're back to the lake it's
very large annual puts
the watersheds varies between and 10 to
15 percent of the lake volume so now if
you're changing
the amount of phosphate going into the
lake in a given year
you're not going to see that right away
you have to wait and at least
five years six years two years whatever
what is it how can you
how can you do that well i puzzled over
that for a while
one of the real key issues is in 1972
the chloride
in the lake had increased to about a
hundred parts per billion
and uh steve effler and his group
uh
noticed that that had
started the car and started to go down
once they quit putting that
the fines in the lake from
uh the excess of the mining
it's 100 parts per million in 1970
by
1976 it's gone down to about 60 parts
per million and you can see that's kind
of a gradual decrease approaching
probably
the current chloride steady state in the
lake of around 55 parts per day so that
tells us right off hand oh
okay that lake's big and cold i just
said we got problems
so okay
here things get now we start looking at
stream flow
and
this graph is
through the 2010
the green things are yearly
uh
loaded well no it's this is full yearly
flow data notice
the black line
which is five year rolling average and
how that goes through episodes
of high and low flow
so now we say oh wait a minute how are
we going to average this over
years if we sort of say hey the amount
of flow determines the amount delivered
to the lake
okay so here's the here's the approach
we first of all on the far left
graph we've seen that before that's
chloride in the lake
as it decreases over time the second
graph
is the delivery of water that flow into
the lake
five-year averages
the next one is the concentration
versus flow
we're going to combine those
the two middle ones and then we have to
see if what we can do
to get that
to finally see how that impacts
the
phosphate in the deep lake
so we've got all of that together
uh and so how many
years now now here's where things get a
little messy maybe
so look
i know what the flow is for this history
uh the
concentration box plot tells me
how that
concentration is distributed as we go
through flow regimes
there are 750 samples in that box plot
now we're going to say ah
we've got that that's good data so now
we start our
our
matrix
the first column we list
the uh let me go back i think maybe a
little clear if we start
the first column in that now i think not
it's hard to
get this all tied together
the first column we list the
concentration of the leaf lake
that's for each year 1999 to 2011.
the next column is
the amount of flow
or the load
the preceding year
the second column
is the average load over the two
preceding years third column
is uh
three years etc it said all the way out
to 10 years
so we've got that so now
here's a just sort of a piece of the
matrix we've got a year late p first
year taking care of it all out to 10 etc
okay
now we take
we look at the
we put this into a
correlation
coefficient matrix
uh
i mean it's a little those little of
small but let's say so these are the
correlations
the
second column in is uh
the
correlation coefficient between the
phosphate and the lake
and the stream average input
for the first year
second year third year fourth year etc
and if you look at the correlation
coefficients first one year forget about
it
second year it's a little better third
year's better still finally you get to
six years you get a correlation
coefficient of 0.89
my interpretation is ah
that's the key issue is
summarize stream flow
or stream inputs over six years
and that should be correlated well it is
correlated obviously with the phosphate
and the d plate
and i want to call you your attention to
the right hand column
which indicates the number of days
in that average
now remember
the concentration
the the box plot
was concentration
for flow regimes for a flow
rate essentially
well we've used the usgs data we know
what the flow is every day for
how many years you want in there
and it's about 2 000 days go into that
six year average
so if we've done a good job of getting
an unbiased sample of
flow regimes based on
uh our 750 samples all we're doing is
just taking samples of that out and
applying it to 2000 days so
i think this is
this is this is a pretty unbi i think
this is pretty unbiased
the whole problem may be biased estimate
of how to do it
but in terms of the loading of phosphate
from the stream
i think that's a pretty unbiased
estimate
so we've
okay we've
got the stream inputs averaged over the
previous six years is about the best
concentration
of deep water in the lake
so now there are about four variables
that we pick as really important
and this is correlation matrix
2000-2011
10 degrees of freedom
okay the first the six-year business
that's the six-year
input from the stream
the eff is
the
deep
water measured in the effluent
from the lake source cooling system
the lake elk
lk
uh
apr is
the measured phosphate in the lake in
april which is part of the lake source
cooling data
all the chlor all chl is
chloride for the whole like our
chlorophyll for the whole lake
uh
well the correlated one percent
probability correlation coefficients
0.68
uh
obviously the
chlorophyll and the other things is sort
of okay
particularly you want to call your
attention to the
six-year correlation with
the effluent that's the measured deep
concentration
the the
lake
phosphate in april is not the best
all all chloride in the summer is not
bad
and anyway
i think those are reasonable correlation
coefficients
considering
this is kind of 40 years of
experience from
lots of different
sources of samples etc etc
so
we pretty well it's here's my summary of
the relationships we started out and
i think that the correlation
coefficients pretty well
say well yep that's not too bad
i just summary here's srp in the lake in
the summer
versus that's the phosphorus in the
lake in the summer versus a secure
average from stream inputs
summer chlorophyll six-year average is
stream inputs
there's obviously a lot of things to be
done there here's just four of those
things kind of put together
all right let's get down to the general
summary
uh
okay so what have we learned
the phosphate concentrations varied from
4 to 15
micrograms per liter
1974-2011
concentration of phosphate in the spring
is correlated with the six year average
of phosphate input from the streams
chlorophylls increased and decreased in
phase with the variation
in phosphate
but there's a lot of variation that's
not explained by the phosphate
this is a multi-variable
problem
most likely
things to look at more carefully
is temperature
solar radiation
wind etc etc well
i looked at that a little bit and i
decided it was beyond my
ability to deal with it i didn't have
the data i thought anyway
the second one chlorophyll conservation
has varied from 4 to 10 micrograms per
liter
and within the period 68
to 2011
and i would argue
that we have covered
a lot of
history of the lake
if we want to look for the guide to the
future
i would say
you could look at the chlorophyll
concentration but
since you go to
other things you can look at the deep
lake
or
six years or whatever
there's a lot of variability but
that's going to happen
one of the things that i think is very
very important
a lot of people
i think at least my scuttlebutt is
they look at the lake and says oh it
looks terrible it must be all that
phosphorus that went in it's all that
chlorophyll
that's really far far from the truth the
reality is there are a lot of suspended
silence
that are consequence of all those
sediment all the sediment that's gone in
with all the storms
and that's all mixed up
with chlorophyll
and if you really look at chlorophyll in
a very clean lake
uh this the
lake's very clear
and it looks clean etcetera etcetera so
i think
a lot of
misinformation and whatever
about the way that
the lake looks
is not necessarily just chlorophyll it's
partly chlorophyll
but very often if you look today i don't
know i haven't looked today but the last
two or three days you see a lot of
stuff in the lake right
that's sediment from storms
it's spring chlorophyll is almost zero
and during summer concentration varies
widely believe me it's
not sloppy lab stuff
they're real variations in
chloride chlorophyll during the summer
the other thing that i think is very
very important the phosphate dissolved
in the water has no important influence
on the macrophytes that is the so-called
weeds those big things
they're usually restricted to the
shallow water less than 68 meters in
depth
so
a lot of people sort of think oh that
must be phosphorus in the lake
water
that's influenced in the proliferation
of those microphytes
well
some maybe but mostly they get their
phosphate from the sediment
so if you want to predict future
chlorophyll and algae growth
uh
you can look at
the phosphate in the lake source cooling
water and i presume cornell will
continue
to
sample that water
and we've seen
from past history
what that deep water concentration of
phosphate
will do in terms of chlorophyll in the
lake
so you don't have to do all this stream
sampling
just rely on cornell to keep monitoring
the phosphate and the effluent from
the core schooling if you don't like
cornell's data john hoffman at hobart
william smith has collected and
published several years
of data in far more detail than the lake
source cooling data so if he continues
his work we need not
duplicate it
with the future consultants and dec are
well-developed lake and watershed models
by 2 to 17 so they say there will be a
tmdl total maximum daily load model
i have an opinion that currently the
quality of the lake is very good to
excellent
but the great challenge is invasive
invasive species
do we know how to manage them
oh very good thank you
and questions
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu